elle s'appelle ludivine juliette
alexandrine marie-christine fabienne ou
marié mais elles sont vigneronne
oenologue ou sommelière reconnu en
bourgogne en france et pour certaines
largement au delà
[Musique]
aux antipodes de l'image d'epinal du
vigneron d'antan mal bourru et un peu
machiste sur les bords
elle présente un nouveau visage de la
bourgogne féminin et moderne longtemps
bannie des caves est rejeté dans l'ombre
de leurs pères de leurs frères ou de
leurs maris les femmes sont désormais
sur le devant de la scène à la tête
d'exploitations viticoles ou responsable
de la vinification des vins
grâce au combat de leurs aînés elle
occupe une position qu'elles n'ont
jamais eu dans l'histoire du vignoble
mais pour arriver aux places qui sont
les leurs aujourd'hui elles ont dû se
battre plus que les hommes faire preuve
de plus de détermination montré plus
d'envié et au passage bousculer quelques
habitudes et pas mal d'idées reçues
[Musique]
tous
alors non seulement à sur la colline de
corton puisqu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train de récolter la parcelle d corton
grand cru les bressans
[Musique]
ludivine griveaux est la première femme
à occuper le poste de régisseur des
hospices de beaune
depuis leur création en 1443
oenologue elle a la responsabilité des
60 hectares deux premiers et grands crus
vendus chaque année lors de la plus
célèbre vente de charité vinicole au
monde
regardez ce décor
on a quand même de la chance d'avoir un
bureau 60 hectares quand on travaille
aux autres
elle a sous ses ordres une équipe de 23
vignerons dont 22 hommes bonjour ça va
vous voulez chargé pas trop parce que ça
va peut-être le trier que cet après midi
stocks
d'accord vous des fois quand on est sûr
fallait pas les palettes elle écrase
l'abri sur ce qui dépasse sur evault
love you man la caisse donc fait vaut
mieux un peu plus de quatre mois lourde
que son nom
à son arrivée aux hospices de beaune en
2015 ludivine griveaux a débarqué dans
un milieu d'hommes tous plus âgés
qu'elle est plus ancien dans le métier
c'était dur déjà parce que l'institution
l'a toujours été moderne et
avant-gardiste tout en étant ancré dans
une histoire lourde porte et étant la
première femme ici ce domaine ça a déjà
et voilà ça c'était déjà un premier coin
mais c'est pas normal d'avoir à
l'accepter c'est comme ça voilà or il a
fallu une phase d'acceptation
c'est un peu ça qui l'y a été difficile
parce qu'on n'a pas envie de se faire
accepter parce qu'on est un homme ou une
femme ont envie de se faire accepter
parce qu'on est bon ou pas bon mais
parce qu'on montre ce dont on est
capable on est 23 vignerons et bacata
petit on s'acclimate à ce changement est
on
c'est sûr que ça n'a pas été évident
pour divine de se retrouver avec plein
de trois hommes comme ça c'est tout con
leurs habitudes donc mais bon on
s'acclimate et puis tout doucement basse
a fait son chemin et ça se passe plutôt
bien
on nous attend pas au même temps nous
attend sur une peut-être une certaine
résistance à la pression a physiquement
il n'y a aucun problème se dire que
quand on voit là on ne demande pas de
soulever des choses des charges louron
cepal sur l'aspect physique c'est plutôt
sur l'aspect prise de décision rapidité
d'exécution et c'est un peu plus
attendre ludivine griveaux n'est pas
issu du monde du vin ses parents étaient
commerçants et industriels
l'arrivée de cette jeune femme de moins
de 40 ans aux hospices de beaune a
bouleversé les habitudes et modifier
certains comportements
moi c'est ça si on est moins familier je
tutoie y ait effectivement le précédent
vicieux voilà donc je suis resté au bout
mais c'est vrai que ça change
effectivement peut-être quelque chose
comme ça mais on les change différemment
peut-être la façon des changes est
peut-être plus différente
ce serait différente sa force au calme
et au respect de tous
[Musique]
quelques kilomètres plus au sud dans le
village de givry une jeune femme de 29
ans dirige la manoeuvre dans la cour de
son domaine
juliette joblot a repris le domaine
familial il ya cinq ans après quatre
générations d'hommes dont son père jean
marc et son oncle vincent qui ont lissé
le domaine au plus haut niveau de
l'appellation givry
j'aime bien les parfaits
vous avez une volonté en me disant oh
quel bel outil de travail ont fait d un
fabuleux on voit qu'ils sont bues dans
le monde entier donc ça rapproche les
gens on peut parler 20 à l'autre bout de
la planète on part un peu le même
langage donc c'était fabuleux à ce
niveau là mais voilà la crainte de
retravailler en famille dans un milieu
d'hommes qui ont été élevés mon oncle
mon papa ont été élevés à la valeur
paysanne des choses c'est à dire que la
vraie valeur du travail c'était la
valeur du travail physique
je me souviens mon grand père voilà qui
disait vendre le vin ou répondre aux
clients ou parler du vin ou commerce
c'était pas du travail quand on faisait
ça les week-ends et puis les soirs donc
que dans leur tête ça a toujours été ça
cette partie où on aujourd'hui on essaie
de faire un peu de commerce de faire un
peu de marketing voilà faire déjà une
plaquette pour que les gens soient
contents de venir leurs nouveaux tarifs
ça fait de manière joli ça bon et je
pense qu'ils trouvent ça tous ridicules
mais mais c'est pas grave je me fais
quand même à dix on va pas y aller bien
longtemps mais on va y aller
ça va venir
je croise les doigts
parce que ça craque
quand on est une femme on a l'impression
qu'à des métiers qui nous sont interdits
je pense que ça l'est moins qu'avant
mais bon
disons qu'elles sont obligées d'être
excellentes voilà elles ont regagné leur
liberté quand même des femmes
incompétentes france métier
en tout cas celle qui reprennent les
domaines sont des fortes personnalités
et on entend parler d'elle un juliette
elle sait où elle va en tout cas sa
forte personnalité de l est en devenir
mais y'a bon terroir et inventer roi
ouais en actes
juliette joblot est aujourd'hui la seule
vigneronne à la tête d'un domaine sur
les 40 vignerons de l'appellation givry
et si elle a fini par prendre ses
marques
la reprise de l'exploitation familiale a
été délicate
ça s'est passé de manière compliquée
compliquée avec justement c'est ces deux
personnes avec qui j'étais mon oncle et
mon père qui avait une éducation très
paysanne très rustique
voilà on n'a pas trop place pour la
sensiblerie pour les sentiments pour on
dit parce qu'on pense encore unis peut
donc c'est tout c'est très bruts quoi
c'est une habitude très brut et c'est
peut-être féminin c'est peut-être de
nouvelle génération
mais on a besoin de communiquer les uns
les autres et ça a mis du temps
ouais ça a mis du temps aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est un peu apaisées entre
tout le monde sait bien mais ses amis
famille 50 parce que ça se passe très
bien on arrête de strips et
je pense que mon papa avait besoin d'eux
d'avoir confiance il n'avait pas
confiance voilà que pour ça que j'ai
choisi un un ami à l'époque qui était
dans le vin je m'étais dit s'il n'a pas
confiance en moi d'arrêter de confiance
en lui voilà mais bon rétrospectivement
ce n'est pas la solution
aujourd'hui voilà j'ai un ami qu'il faut
autre chose et c'est très bien comme ça
ça me prouver à moi même que c'est
possible
[Musique]
on
c'est 90
[Musique]
à la différence de juliette joblot
alexandrie droit n'a plus rien à prouver
et lui vigneronne de l'année en 2015
elle élabore des vins dont la réputation
dépasse aujourd'hui largement les
frontières de l'hexagone
elle a succédé à son père marc en 2003 à
la tête d'un petit domaine de 4 hectares
sur la commune de gevrey-chambertin elle
fait partie des rares vigneronne aussi
intéressé par le travail de la vigne que
par celui de la cave
je me plais c'est pas dans le bureau a
des ratés des bouts de papier je suis
quelqu'un du dehors
j'aime pas être enfermé
ça m'a toujours intéressé mais au début
je pensais pas forcément en avoir la
capacité physique justement parce qu'on
nous conditionne à dire que c'est dur
c'est dur c'est dur qui en gros c'est
pas spécialement fait pour nous quoi et
bon bah c'est vrai que mon père c'est
quand même quelqu'un de super robuste et
quand même lui je le voyais rentrer
complètement à plat
je me disais en gros c'est bon aussi lui
il est dans cet état là moi j'ai pas
survivre
on a du coup la force physique que j'ai
pas forcément comme lui cela compense
par par des kits technique les petites
astuces quoi on arrive toujours à
trouver un moyen quand on est plus
costaud de bouger les choses ou de lever
les choses sans se tracasser lbo
il faut parvenir à être crédible et j'ai
jamais joué justement sur le côté sexy
des vigneronnes la preuve je suis plutôt
sur sur les faits le 20 il est bon ben
voilà ça c'est un fait précis qui n'a
rien à voir avec avec du maquillage ou
ou le sexe à personne parce que le chou
c'est un raccourci un peu facile et puis
pas forcément flatteur
au delà des clichés sur la force
physique des femmes qui leur interdirait
certains métiers
alexandrine roy a aussi dû surmonter les
stéréotypes et les idées toutes faites
qui assigne aux hommes et aux femmes
déroule bien précis dans le monde du vin
c'est pas toujours évident quand on a
juste une fille de dire est ce qu'elle
va faire la vie mais c'est ça va
s'arrêter le domaine va s'arrêter là
alors que ça très bien scooter c'est
super
mon père sait tout faire sauf les
garçons veulent été déçus continue
toujours pas du tout alors pas du tout
ils avaient si j'ai la chance
aujourd'hui de faire vraiment la partie
production
je pense sans trop me tromper que c'est
parce que j'étais qui est unique
pourquoi parce que s'il y avait eu un
garçon
naturellement on serait on aurait plus
porter les espoirs entre mi-mai de
travail physique de vigne et de vin sur
lui que sûrement parce que c'est les
schémas classiques et parce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
[Musique]
alexandrine juliette ou ludivine ne
représente plus d exception en bourgogne
loin de là
de nombreuses femmes dirigent
aujourd'hui des domaines viticoles où
travaille comme monologue dans
l'élaboration des vins
mais ce qui semble aujourd'hui une
évidence ne l'était pas du tout il y a
deux générations à peine
[Musique]
et
des femmes il y en a pourtant toujours
eu beaucoup dans les lignes la taille
l'ébourgeonnage les vendanges
beaucoup de travaux viticoles souvent
pénibles étaient assurées par les femmes
est depuis très longtemps mais elle
restait toujours dans l'ombre jamais sur
le devant de la scène
il y à 50 ans à peine
les femmes qui avaient leurs règles
était toujours interdite de caves en
bourgogne au nom de vieilles
superstitions qui prétendait qu'elle
risquait de faire tourner le vin
pendant longtemps le terme vignerons ne
sait conjuguer qu'au masculin et imaginé
une femme diriger un domaine viticole
était simplement impensable
[Musique]
le
on
[Musique]
je vais kida servane a débarqué en
bourgogne en 1967 aux côtés de son mari
artiste peintre new yorkais
elle découvre alors le monde du vin et
celui ci va devenir une passion
dévorante
dix ans plus tard elle est la première
femme à exporter des vins de
propriétaires aux états unis voilà le
début des choses
79 la société a était né le 18 mai 79
infecté vous béquille wasserman fait
partie du petit groupe très fermé des
femmes pionnières qui ont osé
s'aventurer dans un monde alors
exclusivement masculin presque tous les
interlocuteurs avec qui elle travaille
alors sont des hommes aux états unis et
avait eu une seule femme qui était sommé
hier une femme très digne dans le
michigan était superbe
ainsi des femmes quand même dans ce
qu'on peut appeler les relations
publiques
quelques femmes dans les magasins mais
dont le dont le travail a pas beaucoup 0
d'ailleurs mais ici aussi c'était un peu
la même chose y avait eu deux ou trois
femmes qui ont hérité des domaines et
qui ont vraiment travaillé à avec mais à
part ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui une
vigneronne
c'était des personnes des femmes qui ont
dirigé des entreprises mais à pas femmes
vignerons c'est-à-dire tracteur cuverie
et cetera non
mais qui va servane a vécu le moment où
les choses ont commencé à bouger
elle a vu les mentalités évoluent et peu
à peu et un nouvel avenir s'ouvrir pour
les femmes dans le monde du vin
certaines jeunes femmes ont dit à leurs
pairs ça c'est ridicule on va venir dans
les cuveries on voudrait travailler et
ça c'était à peu près à peu près dans
les années 80 quand c'était les les
commencements des choses et quand ça a
commencé ouvrir pour les femmes les
portes étaient ouvertes très rapidement
très rapidement mais grâce à des
personnes qui ont lu telus telus t et à
pour être respecté
le village de vosne-romanée au coeur de
la côte de nuits abrite aujourd'hui
plusieurs domaines dirigées par des
femmes
parmi ces domaines celui des soeurs
m'ignorer comme tout le monde les
appelle dans le milieu présente la
particularité rarissime d'être un
domaine 100% féminin si tu veux mais au
fait les dessus que moi je vais faire
embarquer ce que j'ai l'âge et
l'annuaire
oui je me débrouille tout seul par
contre je laisse peut-être assister ta
maman là pour le nettoyage
dis-moi faut chercher dans ces cas nous
sommes trois générations maman
jacqueline marie andrée et moi ces
filles et lucie notre fille donc la
petite fille de jacqueline et voilà
trois générations qui travaille alors
maman m'ont plus maintenant mais qui ont
travaillé ou qui travaillent
actuellement dans la cave en 1988 à la
suite du décès prématuré de leur père
marie-christine et marie-andrée mugneret
se sont retrouvé brutalement aux côtés
de leur mère jacqueline aux commandes du
domaine familial
à une époque où très peu de femmes
encore dirigé des exploitations
viticoles et agricoles 89 a été un
millésime assez difficile parce qu'il
faisait très très chaud et il a fallu
improviser pour pour rentrer une
vendange pas trop chaud de donc là vous
vous dites qu'est ce qu'il aurait fait
qu'est ce qu'ils auraient fait comment
est ce qu'il aurait géré et puis je
crois que c'était un peu notre force de
d'être toutes les trois c'est que on
arrivait à se supporter
dans le bon sens du terme vraiment a
cédé et face à des situations qui
n'étaient pas toujours faciles et des
grands moments de découragement on s'est
senti investi d'une mission qui était de
poursuivre le travail des grands parents
et de le faire le plus logiquement
possible et ça s'est fait naturellement
voilà mon mari avait quand même un aura
particulier en tant que médecin et
autant de vignerons il avait une
personnalité et je pense que mes filles
en ont bénéficié
c'étaient les filles et un jean minerai
c'est une carte de visite en quelque
sorte et ça leur a permis à près de se
faire un noël dans le métier
il faut quand même reconnaître autre
chose c'est que quand papa est décédé
il avait quand même organiser les
affaires de telle façon que le domaine
était vendu lui connaissait la
difficulté du métier l'investissement
que cela demandait et il avait dit c'est
pas que je ne me sens pas capable de le
faire mais vous avez laissé votre vie de
famille on s'est lancés soit toi tu es
puisque moi j'étais étudiant je dois lui
aussi réussi et tdc on a décidé le
domaine seraient fermées le mercredi
parce que le mercredi c'est le jour des
enfants donc on va dans quelque part on
va exaucer le souhait de notre père en
disant on va essayer de lier les deux la
vie de famille et le ca sera possible on
verra on verra
marie-christine et marie-andrée mugneret
ont relevé le défi et assurer la
pérennité du domaine c'est un marc elle
aussi pour faire du vin il faut vraiment
l'oeil et l'oreille l'oreille le goût et
l'odeur en septembre
lucie la fille aînée de marie christine
est revenu sur l'exploitation pour
reprendre le flambeau et à nouveau une
génération exclusivement féminine va
prendre la direction du domaine
pour l'instant je suis le modèle qu'on
commençait mon grand père puis ensuite
et ma tante mais dans un certain sens ça
peut mettre la pression sur voilà nous
on est la cinquième génération avec ma
soeur et mes cousines qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir nous faire tout en en préservant
le domaine qu'on nous a que les
générations précédentes nous ont
transmis pour pour qu'elle soit toujours
je dirais aux fiers de nous et pour
continuer à perpétuer ce ce beau domaine
viticole au début des années 90
l'expérience des soeurs mugneret
approuvé à une nouvelle génération de
femmes qu'elles pouvaient exercer le
métier de vigneronnes à l'égal de leurs
homologues masculins
[Musique]
à givry juliet zhu glos a fini par
prendre ses marques dans le domaine
familial
c'est elle qui prend aujourd'hui toutes
les décisions à la vigne dans
l'élaboration des vins ou pour leur
commercialisation sur la plante après on
fait les plombiers et après on parle de
vent le vent on voyage un peu c'est un
beau métier oui
il lui a fallu du temps pour imposer ses
idées se faire accepter de tous et venir
à bout des dernières résistances
[Musique]
en 2010 j'ai travaillé dans les rails du
domaine boulot voilà donc on a on a fait
comme on faisait façon il fallait que je
vois d'abord c'est une évidence toute
façon et puis en 2012 j'ai commencé à
proposer d'autres choses des petites
choses des petits réglages au début
pierre bon ça a été compliqué de les
mettre en place il a fallu batailler un
peu mais on y arrive et voilà en 2012
j'ai pu enfin m'occuper j'ai commencé
par les blancs vraiment où j'ai changé
tout de a à z
ils ont bien voulu donc je suis content
que le résultat est là on je pense
qu'ils ont progressé il me semble et
puis et puis voilà petit à petit depuis
2012 je change des petites choses sur
les vins surtout en rouge maintenant on
ya pensé encore un peu de boulot quoi
[Musique]
l'idée c'est garder la trame parce que
j'aimais les vins qu'on ne va pas
refuser mais on a toujours un moyen de
se perfectionner de garder cet esprit
vanguard et en même temps de dire
peut-être que sur la jeunesse ils
peuvent être peut-être plus aimable
encore je vais me mettre
tu veux tu me mets entre non un peu trop
en arrière
ces visuels
ces visuels que ce soit joli quand on
descend y en a qui le font au cordeau
mais nous on le fait à l'oeil
il faut que ça ça séduisent l'oeil
j'essaie de gérer tout ça de gérer une
boîte de gérer des gens de reprendre
aussi parce que on récupère des salariés
qui étaient là déjà sur mon papa et
enfin avec mon papa au domaine
moi j'arrive quoi je suis la fille des
bons j'ai fait des études ça me rend un
peu plus crédible mais mais je reste à
la fille de quoi donc on a bossé
ensemble dans les vignes fait trois
saisons comme ça donc j'ai bossé avec
eux au quotidien
et puis après j'ai pu prendre un peu de
recul et puis m'occuper plus de la
partie gestion partie commerce et s'est
installé comme ça et au niveau des
clients je pense que c'est là où ça va
être plus compliqué quand même j'ai
quelques clients un peu macho misogyne
j'en ai quelques-uns ouais encore qui
qui me parlent assez mal je me
paraissait mal en disant votre papa je
voudrais votre papa ou dans un sens que
là je sens bien que c'est le côté
féminin qui veulent clairement pas
traiter avec une fille
[Musique]
voilà
je
dans la cuverie des hospices de beaune
lui living rivaux la régisseuse a
rejoint les tables de tri qu'elle
observe d'un oeil particulièrement
aiguisé
[Musique]
alors ces actrices à et vous on va
butter pas vous répondre
dix d'entre eux
mais quand tu n'es pas mûres
là c'est juste pas bon parce que le
raisin il a une petite imperfection
la séquence est pas mûres d'accord mais
là c'est murin savent ou pensent pas
encore passés telle question comprenait
pas
c'est complètement humain et ça arrive
très souvent mais on voit qu'on puisse
des heures ou des jours les équipes
deviennent trop sévère en fait c'est une
déviation complètement naturel on la
voit c'est pas la première qu'est ce
qu'on passera pas la dernière
mais du coup sari et talonne un peu tout
le monde à effacer aussi moore
[Musique]
bon bah c'est bien là
cette voie ces piges et ça va
attends je vous ramène la caisse
quant à ma place je me sens dans mon
élément
la ville yves c'est l'aboutissement de
ton travail d'avants bien sûr mais c'est
une
c'est encore autre chose c'est un peu
plus de toi c'est un peu plus
d'introversion sans parler de fort ou
pas fort mais il faut déjà un
tempérament assez disponible parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses à gérer en même
temps et beaucoup de sujets on passe
d'un sujet à un autre très vite et les
gens qui sont enfin merci hein tu
pouvais pas prévenir un taf extraire tu
me prends pour une stagiaire que tu
visites en fait à l'hercules film
ouais c'est un vrai qu'il faut c'est ça
c'est d'abord de la disponibilité parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à gérer
et du coup il faut un tempérament avec
du sang sera et puis après west du quart
à sion pour mener les hommes et
et les femmes
[Musique]
voilà
c'est pas si évident dans l'esprit des
gens qu'un petit bout de bonne femme
puisse prendre un poste déjà aussi
prestigieux en plus un poste exposé et
en plus un poste technique
alors effectivement très vite cette
attente de la part de l'équipe chez moi
en tout cas ça a généré le fait de
vouloir prouver plus faire plus leur
montrer que j'étais quand même capable
malgré peut-être des inquiétudes
il n'y a pas eu de réticence mais il y
avait des inquiétudes il vaut mieux
qu'ils mettre la main sur des palettes
moi je vais pas du tout placé en
situation de victime n'a aucune
victimisation c'est vraiment pas mon
tempérament
maintenant il faut dire les choses ouais
on en bave à des postes comme le mien et
mais en même temps quand on fait ses
preuves même qu'il faut les faire dix
fois plus
au final on les fait et au final on
arrive à avoir un peu cette ce pied
d'égalité
voilà on repart un peu tous tous ou même
sur la même ligne
[Musique]
si elles ont dû lutter et même si elles
doivent parfois le faire encore pour
gagner leur place
les femmes semblent aujourd'hui
solidement installé dans le monde du vin
dans une bourgogne
encore profondément marqué par ses
traditions
une question se pose alors les
nombreuses vigneronne qui travaille
aujourd'hui en bourgogne font-elles le
vin différemment de leurs homologues
masculins
[Musique]
alors ça c'est une grosse légende de
dire raza servane femme ça st
c'est un homme parce qu'alors
franchement pour se planter karajan tél
alors après il ya toujours des
raccourcis possible désir à s'épuiser
élégance et puis si c'est plus ça donc
on se sent que c'est sans que c'est une
femme qui a fait ça sauf que des fois
c'est vrai et puis des fois ça ne l'est
pas et moi je connais des femmes qui
vinifie des vins très très dur tannique
avec beaucoup de matière beaucoup
d'extraction et voilà c'est pousser
vraiment plus une question de de style
et de préférence
le vin c'est revisité sait jamais la
même chose toute façon donc moi j'ai
juste repris la trame de départ qui nous
plaisent énormément puis après j'ai fait
à ma sauce comment dire après souvent ce
qui ressort c'est que il ya plus
peut-être dans ce que je fais de finesse
et d'élégance
c'est possible mais encore une fois ça
dépend vraiment du ressenti propre à la
personne moi j'ai peut-être pas le recul
pour le voir parce que parce que de ce
que je lis les articles qui sortent
depuis un certain nombre d'années depuis
que je refais les vins touche de
féminité notable c'est donc peut-être
peut-être que peut-être que j'essaye de
de faire des vins un petit peu plus rond
moins austère mais
peut-être ça peut-être dans l'idée de
quand même faire des voix des vins un
peu moins sont moins strictes ouais que
faisait mon papa tout ça c'est sûr après
ce que s'il avait un fils il aurait eu
la même idée
peut-être fantasme ou réalité
les 20 de femmes sont devenues à la mode
fabienne parra a été l'une des plus
jeune sommelière de bourgogne au début
des années 80 il y a trois ans elle a
ouvert son bar à vin qui est devenu
rapidement un lieu incontournable des
soirées beaunoise parmi les 1200
références de vins qu'elle propose
on trouve de nombreux vins de
vigneronnes moi j'aime beaucoup les 20
de femmes
genève un homme bien sûr mais j'aime
beaucoup des 20 de femmes et je me
propose quand même quelques-uns donc je
suis je suis ravie aussi de mettre en
exergue les vingt deux des vingt fait
par les femmes
donc c'est bien c'est mieux je sais pas
il ya un côté alors on va dire féminin
ses côtés un peu enfin c'est un peu bête
de dire ça mais je sais pas il ya
toujours on reconnaît toujours la patte
d'une famille atur une petite finesse
une élégance qu'on n'a pas forcément
chez les vins faits par les hommes
quoique la touffeur deux exceptions mais
je trouve voyager pareil j'ai un petit
lien côté sentimental aussi plaît ça me
plaît qu'il ya des nanas qui sont qui
sont super vraiment débuter super
vigneronne qui font du vin
extraordinairement bien travaillé bien
leurs vignes qui se défendent et puis
c'est pas évident d'être dans un monde
donne ce que je suis
j'en fais partie et les gens perçoivent
ça très bien je crois que même une
curiosité pour certains
en fait les gens sur des façons surpris
du côté qualitatif ce qui est enfin ce
qui est un peu bête mais on a toujours
l'impression que les femmes pour moi
mien alors que des fois ils font même
mieux
les femmes sont là et je trouve qu'elles
ont pris leur place c'est maintenant
naturel à une époque c'était un peu
l'oiseau rare
on va dire la curiosité maintenant ça
devient vraiment plus naturel on ne
s'étonne plus d'avoir un vin de femmes
beaucoup moins qu'à 5/10 ans
si bonne forme et aller à la semaine
prochaine
donc cet après midi l'objectif ça va
être de compléter les fûts puisque pour
faire un volume d'environ 5% par an de
20 vous prenez la miette qui contraint
le vin permet de compléter au lycée
viticole de beaune les futures
générations de vigneronnes qui
marcheront un jour dans les pas de
juliette joblot ou alexandrine roi
apprennent leur métier
un car de jeunes filles occupent les
places en formation viticulture
oenologie aux côtés d'un contingent qui
restent encore largement masculin toutes
les filles inscrites dans cette
formation savent parfaitement pourquoi
elles sont là elles sont souvent plus
motivés que les garçons aient déterminé
à faire leur place dans ce milieu
pourtant à les écouter certains clichés
semblent avoir la vie dure
déjà quand on veut prendre des
exploitations quand on est fils de c'est
déjà dur mais alors quand on est des
filles faut faire savoir fois plus
d'efforts enfin montrer qu'on peut en
faire autant que les hommes autant dans
la vigne à la cave qu'on peut porter
qu'on peut on peut en faire autant pour
être rayée et c'est tout aussi dur de
faire sa place même niveau d des autres
etc autant autour de chez nous même au
sein d'une famille ça peut être dur ban
on a la chance d'avoir un père qui me
soutient mais c'est peut-être pas
partout pareil ça fait que les tic dans
dans les familles c'est plus le fils qui
doit reprendre et généralement nous on
voit ça chez nous c'est que je me ferais
c'est destiné à un autre métier on avait
un grand frère alors c'était lui qui
portait l'image de la famille tout le
monde parce que ça me plaisait sur ce
héros
épaules mais finalement ces deux soeurs
jumelles qui est reprendre le domaine
ça impressionne plus que plus que ça
dérange tout à fait ça surprend moi j'ai
un grand frère aussi et lui il a
toujours voulu être dans le vin moi
c'est assez récent et ça a surpris mon
grand père que je vais faire du vin mais
mes parents pas du tout et oui donc nous
on va reprendre à deux donc ça
pour nathalie mado la directrice
adjointe du lycée viticole
les filles sont aujourd'hui parfaitement
légitime dans le monde du vin on forme
des futurs viticulteurs viticultrice nos
log et on se rend bien compte à la base
dans notre formation
il ya une égalité traitement des
étudiants quel que soit leur sexe et on
arrive à des résultats aux examens qui
sont complètement équivalent voire même
parfois supérieures pour tous ces jeunes
femmes
ces jeunes filles n'ont plus de chemin à
parcourir je dirais que c'est à linverse
ce sont les professionnels aujourd'hui
le monde masculin qui a accepté et c'est
eux qui ont encore un long chemin à
faire puisque en termes de compétences
voilà on arrive à une égalité avec les
hommes
et aujourd'hui de nombreuses femmes
l'ont quand même prouvé dans le monde de
la viticulture et voilà les jeunes
filles n'ont plus rien à démontrer
c'est ce sont plutôt les hommes qui
doivent faire ce chemin vers ces jeunes
filles
[Musique]
les vigneronnes n'ont désormais plus
rien à prouver ni dans les caves ni dans
les vignes leur capacité à faire du vin
pour certaines leur talent est reconnu
de tous
chacune à leur manière elle apporte une
sensibilité différente et complémentaire
à leurs homologues masculins
mais à la différence de ces derniers on
leur demande aussi toujours une chose
supplémentaire concilier ce métier
totalement accaparant est une ville
famille équilibrée
[Musique]
chez alexandrine rois le vendredi est un
jour particulier qu'elle réserve à sa
fille romane est âgé de 2 ans comme ça
allait voilà tu fais tout la tape comme
ça déjà tu occupes actionnant bon alors
on en est où
alors concentrons-nous belle tout faux
que maman le travail aussi un peu je
pense que on a bien réussi à organiser
aussi notre emploi du temps de façon à
ce que
chaque chaque personne et chaque élément
et sa place c'est à dire que c'est pas
parce qu'elle est là que le travail s'en
trouve négligé et c'est pas parce qu'il
ya du travail qu'elle est négligée
également on a essayé de trouver un bon
équilibre justement pour qu'elle soit
bien et qu'elles puissent profiter de
ses parents parce que le danger avec des
métiers comme en art c'est tellement
énergivore que ben le risque c'est de
passer à côté
oui c'est moi et donc tu pourrais
essayer d'être domaine pour 11h50 parce
qu'on a rendez vous donc c'est pour ça
que le vendredi c'est la journée que je
passe au bureau donc avec des
alternances de
deux rendez vous clients de rédaction de
mails de réponse est comme ça ça me
permet de profiter des légalement et
d'avoir la continuité sur le week-end
donc en fait en trois jours ensemble
alors tu sais pas tiens regarde ce
qu'elle va faire mal 22 décembre
et c'est ça il ya là la petite série en
route qui est prévu pour pour le 1er mai
mais qui sera mon avis là un petit peu
avant vu ses dimensions
oui il est là le bébé bon je me dis
qu'on a réussi à s'organiser pour la
première bon en théorie c'est des choses
qui doivent venir assez naturellement
peut-être je pense que c'est ouais faut
anticiper en fait faut pas se retrouver
au dernier moment complètement à la
ramasse à dire ouh là là comment je vais
faire pour la garde est ce qu'on demande
à un homme si ils arrivent à concilier
sa vie de papa au travail jamais jamais
on pose cette question
au demeurant c'est bien parce que ça
veut dire que on attribue aux femmes se
mérite supplémentaire celui d'y arriver
quand même gérer cfa la rentrée scolaire
absolument c'était le 4 septembre jour
où on était en vendanges et j'ai dit au
bureau je vous préviens demain matin je
suis pas là avant 10 heures je fais la
rentrée j'ai pas fais tout à fait la fin
de la réunion de présentation de la
classe de 6e pardon mais j'avais prévenu
la directrice d'établissement et ma
fille qui rentre un système ouais je
n'ai jamais raté aucune rentrée et il
est hors de question que je rate une
seule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le troisième week-end de novembre la
ville de beaune ne vit plus que pour la
vente aux enchères des hospices
la plus célèbre vente de charité
vinicole au monde
chaque année les vins du domaine sont
vendus aux enchères à des amateurs venus
du monde entier pour financer l'hôpital
de la ville et des associations
caritatives pour ludivine griveaux c'est
à la fois le début d'un marathon
épuisant l'aboutissement d'un an de
travail et un examen de passage
renouvelé chaque année on n'a pas du
tout les mêmes équilibres at il sur 2017
[Musique]
savait qu'on allait me plaire est ce que
vous avez à peu près de la halle et
quasiment déjà 20 de civils quand même
lui à la confondre avec son prédécesseur
et c'est ce qu'elle fait ce qu'elle
apporte m'intéresse énormément
donc on va voir au fil et à mesure du
temps là
[Musique]
les produits les résultats de ce qu'elle
fait mais c'est intéressant on sent car
plus d'une génération des 15 formations
internationales
magnifique
d'une sensibilité féminine pas faire
peut-être qu'elle vinifie légèrement
différemment
cette dégustation année majeure
demain parce qu'en fait les gens août et
ce qu'on leur avis on prend des ordres
d'achat en direct on oriente et
dégustateur on sait quand et comment
savoir aimé tel ou tel cuvée on leur dit
on va vous avez dû aimer intel
une telle autre en général on se trompe
pas trop parce que comme on a fait les
vins dans on est capable de les
accompagner aussi les piles de les
rassurer parce que c'est toujours un
moment dans un petit peu
important pour eux c'est une aventure
d'acheter une pièce aux hospices et
pauthe
ok
[Musique]
il
enceinte ou non alexandrine roi continue
d'aller taille et ses vignes tant
qu'elle peut le faire comme elle l'avait
déjà fait pendant la grossesse de sa
fille aînée
[Musique]
si j'étais affalé dans mon canapé déjà
je serai très malheureuse ensuite je
serai pas dans cette forme physique là
franchement quand elle bouge page j'en
oublie que je suis enceinte quand ça
bouge pas d'encombrement et là mais sans
plus donc non je fais mes trucs je pense
même nom c'est super c'est super
regardez ça comme c'est joli on dirait
qu'ils sont des bisous j'adore ces deux
là
moi je sais que je suis jamais plus
heureuse qui a pas une bonne journée
bignay miroir là j'ai bien d'avancer je
suis contente ça s'est bien passé
voilà on est content de son travail
et ça c'est essentiel quoi
j'ai vraiment fais ma vie telle que je
la voulais j'ai toujours fait ce que
j'ai vu ça c'est pas courant
j'ai fait que des trucs qui m'ont plu à
moi en fonction de ce que j'avais décidé
donc tu vois je n'ai pas le droit de me
plaindre à aucun moment c'est juste la
vie dangereux
[Musique]
vous étiez déjà venu il ya quelques
années il ya dix ans oui ça c'était le
papa oui c'est sûr à givry
juliette joblot poursuit sa route
tranquillement
c'est elle qui fait maintenant déguster
les vins du domaine aux acheteurs
particuliers qui se présentent au caveau
c'est super bon j'ai vraiment changé peu
près tour dans les blancs et dans les
rouges
l'idée est toujours de faire des vins de
garde mais de les rendre un peu moins
cisterciens jeunes voilà allez vous ai
su qu il moi je fais les bars depuis
2002 voilà chez la fille de jean marc
après quatre générations d'hommes
juliette joblot est en train de réussir
son pari
conjuguer la réussite du domaine au
féminin qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quoi
globalement je pense que je pense que
les gens trouvent ça chouette
en fait je pense que c'est que du
positif mais ça va de plus en plus du
positif qu'elle est une femme qui fait
du montre qu'à que c'est que c'est
possible quoi parce que ça a l'air
tellement impossible et quelques années
bon il faut il faut être entouré de
trois de trot gars costaud mais pour
certaines choses mais bien sûr c'est
possible et donc nous vendons le 127
maintenant
et nous débutons à 16000 par monsieur
c'est bien vu 500 par madame voulez-vous
17 villes monsieur don à 7500 jade juge
dimanche 14 heures la vente aux enchères
des hospices de beaune démarre et elle
va battre pour la troisième année
consécutive un nouveau record
ludivine griot elle a terminé son
travail à la fois héritière des
générations précédentes et pionnière
dans une institution de la bourgogne
viticole
elle a réussi à faire taire tous les
doutes sur sa capacité à assumer ce
poste prestigieux pour ouvrir ses portes
là et puis pour pour les maintenir
ouvertes on a autant besoin de l'effort
des femmes pour nous imposer pour faire
en sorte qu'on soit à nous accepter mais
il faut quand même rendre hommage à tous
les hommes qui nous aident à maintenir
ouvertes et à les pousser ses portes
parce qu'on est quand même pas tout seul
il ya une majorité d'hommes dans le
monde du vin qui se réjouit d'avoir des
femmes à leurs côtés et il y en a même
une majorité qui maintenant sont
capables de dire qu'ils s'en fichent
complètement voilà parce qu'ils ont pour
eux c'est plus une question de jean
c'est une question de compétence
et puis il ya tous ceux que ça dérange
encore pour des raisons qu'on peut
comprendre que moi je que je n'admets
pas mais que je peux comprendre parce
que j'ai presque envie de leur dire
c'est pas de leur faute c'est ce qu'on
leur a toujours dit qu est ce qu on leur
a toujours mis en tête donc à nous de
mettre en tête autre chose dans la dans
la tête de ceux qui arrivent
à givry juliette joblot aura bientôt une
consoeur aux commandes d'un autre
domaine
lorsqu'elle aura terminé ses études au
lycée viticole de beaune marie-aimée
bordeaux montrieux rejoindre à
l'exploitation familiale aux côtés de
son père et de son frère aîné sans le
moindre doute sur ses capacités à y
trouver sa place
ça demande de l'entraînement de
l'expérience fait tout mais à une fois
qu'on a les techniques une fois qu'on
sait comment s'y prendre il n'y a pas de
raison qu'une femme y arrive bien qu'un
homme suffit juste de lui de prendre le
pas quoi mais bon je suis très heureux
qu'ils aient de la suite derrière
en plus d'eux voilà c'est fini
elle la fierté ou et pire on comprend
pourquoi on continue on travaille
ah oui
c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
personne ne sait aujourd'hui combien de
femmes dirigent des domaines viticoles
en bourgogne
mais une chose est sûre les nouvelles
générations de jeunes filles n'hésitent
plus à s'inventer une vie au milieu des
vignes ou dans les caves sous les yeux
souvent émerveillés de leur père en
cinquante ans à peine la place des
femmes dans le monde du vin à changer
radicalement et elles ont désormais
entre leurs mains une partie de l'avenir
du vignoble bourguignon
[Musique]
m